The more ways that the immune system helps suppress cancer and these are really important
when you're trying to treat cancer is number one, it protects us from infections that
can cause cancer.
So and maybe that's one of the best things.
If we have a healthy immune system, the chance of us getting cancer is going to be less.
So remember I said about toxicity.
So our ability to detox things is really important because if we have a really good ability
to detox things, then the chance of us being toxic and ourselves being toxic goes down because
we're all exposed to toxins and how toxic we are really depends on our exposure over
our ability to get rid of those things.
So you aren't what you eat, you are more what you absorb, whether you ate it or not, but
you really you are what you don't detoxify, right?
You've heard me say that before, if you don't detoxify it, it's in your body and it's going
to cause a problem.
Whether it's an inert toxin, like a heavy metal toxin, or it's a biotoxin, if you can't
get rid of it, now a biotoxin will go through the detox pathways, it would be affected by the
immune system.
So the detox pathways may really get rid of inert things, the immune system kills living things.
So immune systems roll in protecting us from cancer is to kill the living things that can
cause cancer.
You've heard of retroviruses and DNA viruses and things that are cancer causing viruses.
H. Pylori will hit that again.
That's a huge nasty one that we're all so exposed to, and how do you get H. Pylori again?
Who is listening?
Hypochloridria, right?
So you have a decreased stomach acid, H. Pylori passes through the stomach, goes systemic,
circulates through the body, can settle in the endothelial tissue, causing inflammation over
15 years, causing heart disease, and you're dropped out of a heart attack, it's all caused
by H. Pylori.
H. Pylori, according to the World Health Organization, is the number one cause of stomach
cancer worldwide.
It's a cause of esophageal cancer, breast cancer, all cancers, H. Pylori can't be the cause
of it.
H. Pylori is a gram negative bacteria just like Lyman X, just like Lyman is sometimes just
difficult to kill his Lyman disease is too, and it could cause autoimmune disease as well.
So biotoxins are a major cause that must be addressed.
So the immune system also helps resolve inflammation that promotes cancer, because part
of the immune system is your T-regulation cells, your T-reg cells, that calm immune response
after that immune response did its job.
So when you have an inflamed immune system to kill off an infection, we want to get rid
it.
We don't want it to constantly go in on, so when it does its job, we need to calm down.
So it's like if you have a marine core, that's like going around our streets and just
killing random things, that wouldn't be good, right?
We need a sergeant that tells them to calm down, will our T-reg cells, part of our immune system
helps calm that down.
So that's important, especially when we get to what promotes cancer.
Immute system can recognize and kill cancer cells, that's a new term that we call immunosurvalence,
your immune system is basically looking for cancer cells.
How does it tell a cancer cell, from a non-cancer cell, because of certain tumor-specific
antigens and tumor-associated antigens that are associated with specific cancers?
All technical stuff that we don't really need to know, but our immune system goes around
and helps kill cancer cells.
So if I don't have a healthy immune system, cancer can grow.
So remember what I said in the last conference, who was here, you watched the videos.
What is cancer, cancer is when cells don't die, that are supposed to die, and cells go
into a rapid replication phase that aren't supposed to go into a rapid replication phase.
That is cancer.
Why that happens is the question of the day.
So why did the cells not die, why did they go into a rapid replication phase?
Well, our immune system is responsible to help with that.
So regardless of why they did a die and why they went into a rapid replication phase, if
I have a healthy immune system, it should still destroy that cancer because cancers will
express certain antigens on their cell membrane.
So if I have in that lecture a couple years ago, I said that there's a third reason why
a person gets cancer, and that is that they have a suppressed immune system at some point
in time.
And I said that definition of cancer is a cell line doesn't go through apoptosis and it
starts with one cell, it doesn't go through death, and then for some reason it goes into
a rapid replication, so it's reproducing cells, the same DNA problem, mutation, that's constantly
reproducing, but your immune system should recognize that as an enemy and destroy it.
So in order for you to get cancer, because the truth is, all of us have cells that aren't
going through apoptosis right now, and some that are going through rapid replication, but
we don't have cancer because our immune system goes, what the heck is that?
Let's kill it, it destroys it.
You don't have cancer.
So you still had to have some suppressed immune system, but it literally could be for a week,
I was really understressing, and I had to do this lecture at a rife conference, and people
were really mean to me.
So just kidding.
The fourth, and maybe one of the more important things about your immune system is that it
kills circulating tumor cells.
This is really important when you're talking about a person that does chemo.
So most of my patients have already done chemo, or are doing chemo, most patients come to
me, they're already in stage four, it's just the way it is.
So they've done chemo, the problem with chemo is chemo, the good thing about chemo is that
it's poison, so it's a poison to cells, and it's attracted more towards rapidly replicating
cell lines.
Well, that's a good thing, right, because you said cancer is rapidly replicating.
That's true, cancer is rapidly replicated, so it will be attracted towards cancer cells.
That's a good thing.
Problem is that there's other cell lines in your body that are rapidly replicating.
Your hair follicles are rapidly replicating, so it will kill your hair follicles and your
hair falls out.
Your immune system is rapidly replicating, that's not a good thing.
So it destroys your immune system, that's why they have to take a blood test and make sure
your lymphocyte level is okay for you to do the next round of chemo, or they'll kill you
with it.
So they survey that.
So the problem is, is that circulating tumor cells are present in every cancer patient.
So long before they even got diagnosed with cancer, you could argue that they have circulating
tumor cells.
That is, cancer stem cells that have broken off the cancer and are looking for another place
in the body to set up a house and raise a family.
Yet, they are not yet rapidly replicating.
So chemo is not going to kill those things.
That's a problem, because what's keeping them at bay right now is your healthy immune system.
So that is why the instance of metastasis goes up post chemotherapy.
If chemotherapy, it knocks down the original tumor, because that's rapidly replicating,
while that's great, the tumor's down to nothing, we're going to do radiation, whatever
next problem is, is that you have circulating tumor cells, and have now moved into a rapid
replication phase that still won't be visible on a PET scan for another year or a half, and
you have what's called metastasis.
Healthy immune system helps keep that at bay.
So if you know anybody that's going through chemotherapy, they better be doing some immune
stimulation as well.
So everything we said, you can't do with the TH1 dominant autoimmune disease.
You better do with a TH2 dominant cancer with any cancer with me.
So here's some ways to stimulate a immune system that you don't want to do if you have TH1 dominant
autoimmune disease.
So remember, this is the flip side of the coin now.
So these are just some ways.
If you look on our website, I probably have 30 different videos of different cancer killers
that I like.
Watch those videos if you can stomach listening to me any longer after this weekend.
But you'll learn about a lot of different good cancer killers that are very good, and I like.